مشاركه يبدو انها كبيره في صور هي الاولى
لانتخابات الاتراك في الخارج طوابير
الناخبين التي تنتظر التصويت في البعثات
التركيه خارج البلاد تنبئ بمنافسه حاده في
جوله الاعاده بين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وزعيم المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوغلو اردوغان
الذي تقدم على منافسه بنحو مليونين ونصف
المليون صوت في الجوله الاولى اختار مناطق
الزلزال المنكوبه لبدء جولته الانتخابيه
وانتقد من هناك خصمه
نرى ان رئيسها حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي
هزم في انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو وفقد
الامل في 28 من مايو يستخدم لغه سامه
وقبيحه اكثر فاكثر انه يحول جزءا من
مجتمعنا الى عدو بتصريحاته المتهوره والتي
تحض على الكراهيه هي فرصه اردوغان للطعن
بخسمه كالجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بعد ردود فعل عنيفه من انصار
مرشح المعارضه ضد سكان الولايات التي
ضربها الزلزال بسبب تصويطهم لاردوكان على
وقع هذه التطورات قرر معسكر المعارضه
تصعيد لهجته بشكل كبير ضد اللاجئين بهدف
جذب اصوات القوميين من مؤيدين مرشح
الرئاسي سنان اوغان
سوريا
انتخابات الجوله الثانيه هي اختيار بين من
يتجنبون ترحيل السوريين ومن يخطط لترحيلهم
خلال عامين المعارضه تعتمد في خطابها ايضا
على الربط بين حزب الدعوه الحره او هدى
بارك الداعم لاردوغان بحزب الله التركي
وما نفذه الحزب من اعمال تصنفها تركيا
بالارهابيه ورئيس اردوغان خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه هو يركز بشكل كبير على
شريحه الشباب بعد التصويت له في الجوله
الاولى في المقابل كريستيانو يحاول اللعب
على وتر القوميه من خلال معاداه اللاجئين
والهدف الاساسي هو كسب اصوات سنان اوغان
قبل اسبوع من جوله الاعاده ستلجا المعارضه
الى خطاب متطرف اكثر تجاه اللاجئين دون ان
تنسى العامل الاقتصادي الذي يراهن عليه
زعيم المعارضه خصوصا في المدن الكبرى
تبدو مهمه زعيم المعارضه اصعب في اقناع
مزيدا من الناخبين بالتصويت له في الجوله
الثانيه خصوصا في ظل حيازه اردوغان
الاغلبيه بالبرلمان وخشيه الناخب من
التعرض بين السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه
فهل ستنجح خطابات المعارضه المتشدده في
تغيير مزاج ناخب ام ان خيار الاستقرار
والتوافق بين البرلمان والرئاسه سيكون
عاملا حاسما زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات